[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about the most eerie and
mysterious member of the ten
commandments esta rosa the love of the
ten commandments esta rosa is the man
who succeeds in killing mellitus at
least temporarily and the man who went
toe-to-toe against the sin of pride
Eskin or himself esta rosa is the
younger brother of Mellie Otis and the
older brother of zeldron
so he is essentially the troubled middle
child while melio descends el dress both
look quite young and childlike despite
the fact that they are actually
centuries old demons esta rosa kind of
looks like an adult version of the two
he even happens to look exactly like
Mellie Otis's original wanted poster
back when he was still a fugitive but as
the seven deadly sins story has gone on
and especially in the manga more and
more questions have been raised about
esta roses true identity to the point
that we have to question who he really
is and whether he is a demon at all in
this video I will be looking at all of
the clues throughout the manga that
suggests that esta rosa is not who we
think he is and that he might have a
shocking secret identity that is going
to be revealed very soon if you enjoy
seven deadly sense content on this
channel and you want to see more you can
let me know by leaving a like and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell and if you want to give us ideas
for future videos feel free to hit us up
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
naturally in order to delve fully into
the evidence I have to dig deep into the
seven deadly sins manga if you are an
anime only person and you don't want
manga spoilers this is your warning
spoilers will follow there is just no
other way to make this video
the first big moment in which I realized
that there was something inherently
different about esta rosa and that this
is likely going to become an important
plot point in the story was in Chapter
236 when Cusack or Cusack however II
want to say it a high-ranked demon who
is the former master of SEL drous tells
us that he always felt that there was
something out of place
esta rosa even though Cusack can't quite
figure out what the source of this
feeling is he knows that there is
something off about esta rosa something
strange and different about him compared
to the rest of the demon clan so what do
we know about esta rosa he is the
younger brother of mili artiss and the
older brother of cedrus and like them he
is the son of the demon king however
even though he is the son of the demon
king esta rosa was apparently born
without any demonic powers aka without
the power of darkness and as a child he
was too scared to hurt even an insect
this is obviously completely out of
place among members of the demon clan
who tend to be vicious and ruthless and
because of his strange nature esta rosa
was looked down on by the demons the
demon king felt sorry for esta rosa
because his two brothers were far
stronger than he was so he decided to
bestow upon esta rosa the commandment of
love and this commandment did give him
enormous demonic power but something
appears to have gone wrong for some
reason having a commandment inside his
body changed esta rosa the power of the
commandment seems to have made a stir
Rosa somewhat mentally unstable as if
the demonic force flowing through his
body was eating away at his psyche we
also know that as a child esta rosa
looked up to his brother meliodas as the
leader of the ten commandments and when
meliodas eventually betrayed the demon
clan this act had a profound effect on
esta rosa we know that he didn't hate
his brother but he was deeply
disappointed and troubled by melioidosis
betrayal
later on in the manga esta rosa absorbs
more Commandments including those that
belong to Galland and wants speed and
this makes him lose control of himself
even further from several flashbacks we
learned that growing up esta rosa always
wanted to be like Mellie Otis but beyond
that esta rosa apparently also fell in
love with Elizabeth at this point in the
story esta rosa starts fluctuating
between wanting to surpass Mellie Otis
one moment and thinking that he is
Mellie Otis in the next moment
and this again emphasizes the fact that
esta rosa has some sort of split
personality
as therosis shifts between thinking that
he is Mellie Otis and that he is the one
Elizabeth loved and thinking that Mellie
Otis at some point agreed to let him
have Elizabeth but then went back on his
word to make the mystery even deeper no
one seems to have clear memories of esta
rosa and Esther Rose's past while in
purgatory Mellie Otis says that he has
memories of zelgius his other brother
but he has no memories of esta rosa and
bond doesn't seem to remember him either
even the demon king esta rosa supposed
father admits in purgatory that he does
not remember esther osa and we are left
with the conclusion that someone has
manipulated everyone's memories about
esta rosa of course we know that go
third the goat sin of lust has the
ability to manipulate the memories of
people on a vast scale although the idea
that he could manipulate the memories of
all the demons and even the demon king
seems pretty insane nevertheless if
everyone's memories of esta rosa have
been manipulated then Esther OSIS past
might be completely different than what
we think
and Esther OSA may not be who we think
he is Esther OSA may have a secret
identity that is going to be revealed as
a massive plot twist in the story you
will recall that Esther Olsen Elizabeth
seemed to have visions or dreams about
each other and in these visions
Esther OSA is shown wearing Armour that
bears the symbol of the goddess clan
similar to the armor that meliodas used
to wear after he betrayed the demon clan
this is interesting considering another
fact that we know about esta rosa during
the previous holy war Esther OSA is
believed to have killed Maya el the
fourth Archangel and of course the four
Archangels are the strongest warriors of
the goddess clan in fact Maya was
believed to be the strongest of the four
Archangels and he possessed the power or
grace known as sunshine the same power
that Eskin or possesses right now
because after Miles death sunshine
somehow passed on to ESCA nor now think
about this
during the vise el festival art when
they first see Eskin or gloxinia asks
droll something interesting when
ESCA noir uses his divine axe Rita
gloxinia asks isn't this magic on par
with Esther OSes as if he sensed some
connection between esta rosa and Eska
Knorr ability sunshine so we know that
there is something off about Esther Ossa
as far as the demons are concerned we
know that he didn't have demonic powers
or the desire to kill even an insect
before he received a commandment and we
know that he has some connection to
Elizabeth and the goddess clan although
Esther OSA is believed to have killed
miele the power which used to belong to
miele known as sunshine reminds gloxinia
and role of Esther Rose's power
something else that stuck out to me was
Esther roses appearance especially after
he consumes multiple Commandments taking
in new Commandments seems to make him
more mentally unstable but his
appearance also changes in a way that
gives him dark wings that have an
angelic shape as well as a dark halo at
this point Esther oh so almost looks
like a fallen angel and if we consider
Miles appearance he too had angelic
wings and his long hair and facial
structure aren't too different from esta
rosa my good friend Knox Tok who also
pointed out that unlike the other demons
Esther Rosa has silver hair which is a
trait common to the Druids who are
closely linked to the goddess clan so
what does all of this mean what is this
neurosis true identity and what is his
connection to the goddess clan there are
multiple options and I will talk about
those options right now the first option
is that Esther osa really is who we
think he is the brother of Mellie Otis
and one of the sons of the demon king
who despite being a demon was born
without the power of Darkness perhaps
the reason he did not have demonic power
is that he was a secret love child of
the demon king and a member of the
goddess clan which the demon king would
want to keep secret because the demon
clan and the goddess clan hate each
other perhaps esta rosa is an adopted
son or perhaps he is just a rare case of
a real demon born without the power of
darkness at any rate if this scenario is
true then my theory is that Esther OSA
did not really kill miele the most
orful Archangel instead I believed in my
el possess'd esta roses body but because
esta rosa is a high-ranking demon and
not a mere human my el failed to control
esta roses body completely which led to
asteroids are developing a split
personality
this would explain why the ability
sunshine left my land somehow passed
down to eScan or a divine grace like
sunshine would not be compatible with
the body of a demon
so when mild possessed esta rosa the
ability split away from him also having
an angelic presence inside him would
explain why a stir osa is so negatively
affected by the power of the
commandments having a commandment the
power of the demon king inside his body
together with the essence of mile the
forth Archangel creates a powerful inner
conflict that makes esther osa
progressively more unstable on top of
all that how else could we explain
esther osis power after receiving his
commandment despite being the weakest
member of his family before he receives
a commandment Esther OSA somehow become
so strong that multiple clues in the
manga suggests that he is the strongest
of all the commandments even stronger
than his brothers ljus if zelgius and
the others all have their own
commandment and they were all far
stronger than esther also before all of
them received their commandments then
how can esther osa be stronger than them
so what i'm trying to say is that the
other demons like childress are starting
off with a much stronger base form so
then after they all receive one
commandment each how can esta rosa who
is supposed to be far weaker all the Sun
surpass zelgius unless Esther roses
commandment for some reason was way more
powerful than sell dresses one potential
solution to this problem is the fact
that Esther osa has mile within his body
and so his power is combined with the
power of the strongest Archangel which
is what gives him an edge over Zell
dress and the others we already know
that members of the goddess clan
including the four Archangels can
possess the body of humans and use them
as vessels so I don't think that this
idea is too far-fetched if we allow that
possessing a demon instead of a human
would create additional complications
such as developing a split person
however this would not necessarily
explain why meliodas the demon king and
the others don't have clear memories of
Esther OSA assuming that Esther OSA is
who we think he is the only reason that
I can think of for the others not
remembering him is that perhaps the
original Gotha the powerful magician who
created the doll Gotha and who had
promised to end the holy war somehow
used esta rosa and mile to end the holy
war but he needed to manipulate the
memories of the others so they wouldn't
figure out what exactly happened the
second option is that Esther OSA is not
who we think he is at all that he is not
even a demon and that the memories of
Esther OSIS childhood were all implanted
on meliodas and the others by Golder
either the original Golder or the dog
older or both so in this scenario Esther
osa could even be the angel Miele
himself not the brother of meliodas or
the son of the demon king potentially
the original Goldar decided to end the
holy war by turning miele the strongest
archangel into a member of the demon
Kings inner circle and he manipulated
everyone including esta rosa into
thinking that he was the son of the
demon king this would make sense if
you're trying to infiltrate a spy into
the inner circle of your enemy and
having a spy posing as the son of the
demon king is a great strategy the only
problem with this scenario is what
exactly was the original goal their
planning to do with esta rosa did he
already use him in some way 3,000 years
ago in order to end the previous holy
war or did the original Gotha place esta
rosa into the inner circle of the demons
as an unwitting sleeper agent waiting to
be activated in the right moment perhaps
by the doll Golder however this idea
that esther osa is not really even
related to Mellie Otis and the demon
king fails to explain why as to Rosa
bears a resemblance to Mellie Otis and
Zell dress and why he basically looks
like an older Mellie Otis and in fact he
looks just like meliodas in his wanted
poster another pretty crazy option is
that when Esther OSA becomes confused
and starts saying that he is meliodas he
might actually be telling the truth
so
we know that meliodas can split himself
into multiple parts using his sacred
treasure and we also know that parts of
meliodas specifically his emotions are
taken from him every time he dies
perhaps the reason why Esther OSA did
not have any demonic powers and wouldn't
kill even an insect when he was young is
that he was created out of Mellie Otis's
good emotions
perhaps the demon king who wanted to
make Mellie Otis's successor decided to
separate the good emotions from Elli
Oda's so he created esta rosa out of
that part of Mellie Otis and so when
Esther osa confuses himself with Mellie
Otis and believes that he is the one in
love with Elizabeth it is because he was
created from Mellie Oris in some way
because Esther also was created out of
Mellie Otis's pure and good emotions
once he receives a commandment he can't
handle it and it corrupts him but while
this theory would provide an answer for
Esther OSes attachment to his brother
and his lack of demonic power it still
doesn't explain why everyone's memories
of Esther oh sub would have been altered
the final option is that the original
goal there was more intimately involved
in the story than we ever realized I
couldn't help but notice that goal Thor
the magician and Esther OSA have some
physical similarities and we know that
Golder had a lover that he cared about a
great deal so could it be that Esther
OSA is the son of the original Golder
and his lover and so in order to protect
him from the demons go through
manipulated everyone's memories into
believing that esta rosa was the son of
the demon king since we know how loyal
dalgo Thur is to his master this would
explain why doll Golder is so interested
in keeping an eye on elisabeth and esta
rosa in the manga personally i think any
of these theories would be an insane
crazy twist to the story but my own
preferred theory is that Esther OSes
body was possessed by the Archangel
Miele but because he is a demon instead
of a regular human this created a split
personality instead of allowing mild to
simply control esta rosa let me know
what you guys think
which of these possible theories is your
favorite and do you have an alternate
theory of your own
let me know down in the comments and
also hit us up on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar as always thank you all
so much for watching I can't wait for
the next chapter of the seven deadly
sins to come out and until next time see
our space cowboys
[Music]
you